we got in just when you think it stops
it just starts up again yeah I'm ready
for it to be done
[Applause]
today we're doing a simulation of
hearing voices I have never done
anything like this before I'm doing the
simulation today for my brother he was
diagnosed with schizophrenia recently I
have a few family members who have dealt
with schizophrenia I'd like to
understand how big the gulf is between
the way I experience the world and the
way someone with schizophrenia would
experience the world my name is autumn
and I'm schizophrenic I was diagnosed
with schizophrenia in 2015 I can
particularly identify two different
voices from my past one is a kind of
raspy masculine deep dark voice that
usually says my name multiple times and
another voice usually tells me to go
different places I've heard up to five
different voices at one time all talking
about different subjects and crowding my
head in chaos it is already hard enough
for people suffering with schizophrenia
to deal with it every single day try to
understand our situation and how it
might be from our point of view I guess
I'm expecting a new understanding I'm
feeling a little nervous about this I
gotta say I hope it provides a different
perspective I see stop it now look at it
eyes are everywhere no good that's right
absolutely I'm gonna start the auditory
hallucination simulator and then just
try to do some basic household chores I
just started and I got to say it's
really creepy I was gonna try to put
away some dishes but I can't really
focus there's a lot of whisper there's a
lot of
oh my gosh this is really creepy I'm
like ten minutes in right now and it's
seriously like terrifying I mean I only
take Seles and the know like the sorry I
can't think I know it's a simulation and
I know I could take the headphones off
at any time but I'm determined to keep
them on at the same time very freaked
out it's hard to articulate now I really
feel like I can't get sentences out oh
one of them just told me I'm disgusting
I tried going for a walk to kind of pass
the time I gotta say being like outside
in an environment that isn't where I
live that I can't really control fully
it's a even more terrifying as I'm
seeing all of this I'm listening through
all this and I'm kind of just
experiencing how hard it is to put
sentences together how it is to talk or
explain or do anything I mean I know
it's a simulation but some of the
cruelty really resonates really good
some okay so I'm just lying in bed now
it's the only thing that feels
comfortable it's just lying in total
darkness I'm ready to be done finished
the auditory hallucination simulator
about five minutes ago
I feel like I still hear it I just did a
short meditation here at home I would
not have been able to do that with the
audio on at all and it takes a lot to
listen through the voices so it's the
next day some of the more cruel phrases
like you eat [ __ ] or you stink you hear
it over and over and over and over and
over again and it starts to really
affect you and wore me out
I do feel closer to my brother now this
was a great eye opening experience I
still would not willingly go through
something like that again
it's allowed me to sort of access that
empathy for them it's our job to learn
what if I could say anything to people
who do not have schizophrenia I would
just like to tell them to not judge
others so harshly we are mostly just
misunderstood we are able to make a
living we are able
to raise families and I hope that one
day everyone in the world is able to see
that
[Music]